assad majed fondateur de dire n'est-ce
consulting cabinet d'analystes sur le
moyen-âge et bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors on vous le disait une affaire qui
intervient à deux mois des élections
présidentielles qui selon le
gouvernement serait une conspiration
pour lui nuire un proche de saad leur
famille à d'ailleurs été écartée du
gouvernement 20 personnes interdit de
quitter le territoire iranien pour
enquêter sur ce fameux enregistrements
la théorie d'une considération certaines
la route selon vous alors précisément il
faut avant tout considérer le contexte
dans lequel cette diffusion ou seul hic
à hâter a été fait
seul hic à avant tout deux buts un but
qui est lié n'est donc en prêtant aux
négociations actuelles de vienne parce
qu'on mentionne en fait quelque part les
discordes une certaine discours d'une
certaine disparité entre l'iran et la
russie chose qui n'est pas nouvelle
parce que de nombreux articles notamment
académique on parlait des disparités
entre les deux pays sur les dossiers
comme la syrie mais surtout compte tenu
du fait qu'on a qu'on s'approche des
élections présidentielles qui vont se
dérouler vers 17 18 juin 2015 j'aurai
des tarifs prêt représente disons une
facette de la population iranienne qui
est enthousiaste pro-occidental très
populaire selon une certaine donne une
certaine étude de marché dont un sondage
zarif était deuxième en popularité
derrière donc qasem soleimani donc ils
représentent quelque part la face est
une des deux facettes de la diplomatie
iranienne sachant que l'autre présentes
et représentées par les gardiens ce qui
a été plus ou moins choquant entre
guillemets pour le papier iranien dans
le cadre de cette interview c'est la
critique puis ou moins de du rôle de sam
soleil manierait des gardiens de la
révolution
alors pourquoi ce leak a été diffusé il
se peut que celui qui a été si on veut
vulgariser ou comparer cela à notre
exemple ça va avoir plus ou moins un
effet de
de lécher fillon dans les années
précédentes élections françaises à
savoir évincé éliminer un potentiel
candidat aux élections présidentielles
même si j'avais tarifs n'avaient pas
exprimé son intention de de se proclamer
ou de se présenter aux futures élections
mohammad sharif a également été convoqué
au parlement pour des propos
contradictoires avec la politique du
pays concrètement que risque-t-il
concrètement une pas grand chose parce
que jared harris représente plus ou
moins une des deux facettes de
fonctionnement de l'état iranien à
savoir on a des institutions qui sont
officielles par exemple le ministère des
affaires étrangères ni certains
intérieurs de me serre la défense et en
même temps toutes ces institutions
officielles sont dédoublés par un autre
système qui est celui des gardiens de la
révolution qui a pour objectif deux
entre guillemets effectuer les
opérations que l'état officielle
iranienne ne peut pas et donc les
critiques de jaouad zarif sont des
critiques plus ou moins normal tout bleu
mat qui croient en dans la fonction
normale d'un système qui n'est pas
bicéphale pourrait se faire alors
plusieurs élus conservateurs on tape les
girouettes saleh à démissionner alors
qu'on est en pleine négociation sur
l'accord nucléaire iranien c'est
d'ailleurs lui même qui est à l'origine
de ce traité établit en 2015 s'il vient
à démissionner ou être écartée l'accord
est tempérée selon vous il ne me semble
pas parce que j'avais arrive déjà avant
que il a déjà présenté il me semble
d'une démission en 2015 qui a été refusé
par l'administration de kani et il me
semble pas que c'est le moment de
démissionner compte tenu qu'il a l'art
et la manière de dialoguer avec ses
homologues américains toutefois le fait
de supprimer un homme ou de d'effacer un
homme de la table de négociation ne
signifie pas que les négociations
s'arrête là
à disons qu'il y a même pendant qu'il y
ait discussion officielle se déroule à
vienne il ya en même temps plusieurs
discussions officieuses qui se déroule
dans d'autres pays
rappelons nous qu actuellement des
négociations secrètes entre l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite se déroule en fait
actuellement en irak
et donc si ce n'est pas en supprimant en
évinçant ministère des affaires
étrangères que le dossier post arrêté
mais en même temps je ne pense pas que
djawad zarif risque de démissionner ou
quitter son poste actuellement merci
beaucoup c'est dommage d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateur de dire n'est-ce consulting
cabinet d'analystes sur le moyen-orient